madame la ministre merci d'être avec
nous secrétaire d'État à la Genèse donc
et au service national universel on va y
venir mais tout d'abord je voulais vous
interroger sur d'autres sujets et
notamment sur la chaîne Viking
234 migrants qui arrivent sur le sol
français
4 expulsions comment est-ce que vous
expliquez ce fiasco vous savez le ciel
Viking c'est exactement une réponse
nécessaire parce que aujourd'hui le
gouvernement italien n'a pas été à la
hauteur du droit maritime et donc nous
avons accueilli effectivement ce bateau
avec une mobilisation de tous
aujourd'hui
qui a accueilli trois bateaux sur 4 oui
mais il y a un pacte européen et quand
on donne sa parole ça a de la valeur ils
ont refusé on en prend acte il fallait
est-ce qu'il fallait laisser ces gens
mourir en mer la réponse est non en
humanité mais en fermeté aussi on a
commencé à instruire les dossiers mais
la réponse ils étaient plus en danger
sur le bateau sur le chemin Viking il
était en danger sur les bateaux des
passeurs mais pas sur nos champs avec
des enfants et des femmes et pour
certains qui étaient malades donc si
leur vie était en danger il fallait à
minima accoster pour pouvoir répondre en
dignité simplement mais soyons en
revenant au cœur de au coeur du sujet si
aujourd'hui il y a une réunion
exceptionnelle des ministres de
l'Intérieur au niveau européen c'est que
la réponse elle doit être repeine parce
qu'ils sont arrivés le pacte de
solidarité est fait ils vont aller sur
un certain nombre de pays et d'État mais
tout ça nous amène au sujet de
l'immigration
77% des Français estiment que le
gouvernement ne maîtrise pas
l'immigration sondage c'est ça pour
cnews qu'on a révélé cette semaine on se
demande pourquoi c'est pas 100% parce
que effectivement de fait le
gouvernement et pas que le vôtre les
précédents également ne maîtrisent pas
les migration 234 personnes qui forcent
la porte d'entrée de la France et on en
expulse que 4 non vous savez nous on n'a
aucun tabou on en a que 4 la réalité
c'est que depuis l'arrivée de du
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin
il y a une volonté ferme même très ferme
de raccompagner chez eux tous les
étrangers délinquants et les chiffres
sont là
étrangers délinquants expulsé est-ce
qu'on peut faire plus est-ce qu'on peut
faire mieux bien sûr mais moi je vais
quand même saluer aujourd'hui sur votre
plateau le travail acharné de nos forces
de l'ordre de nos policiers qui essayent
de les trouver de les de les de les
ramener jusqu'à chez eux et moi j'ai
envie de dire aux Français aujourd'hui
qui nous regardent est-ce que je
comprends ce je comprends cette réalité
ce sentiment et pour faire mieux le
gouvernement avec beaucoup de courage et
bien va changer un certain nombre de
doctrines par exemple le fait de
raccourcir les délais parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un sujet de délai
de permettre de raccourcir de 12 de 12 à
4 les règles pour permettre de faire des
recours c'est ça on le voit là on en a
l'exemple flagrant on l'a sous le nez
234 personnes qui qui rentrent
illégalement sur le territoire on nous
dit vous allez voir ce que vous allez
voir on va les sélectionner il y en a
quatre qui sont explosés c'est ça que
nous avons besoin ça ne fonctionne pas
donc ça ne la réalité
contredit ce que dit le gouvernement
contredit la parole officielle la parole
si elle est simple et très clair est-ce
que c'est facile d'expulser un étranger
non est-ce que notre priorité c'est
d'expulser les étrangers délinquants oui
et d'expulser plus largement ceux qui
n'ont rien à faire sur notre territas la
réponse est oui est-ce que nous avons
besoin d'outils nouveaux législatif oui
bien sûr et c'est pour ça que le
ministre de l'intérieur c'est Gérald
Darmanin présente un texte de loi après
je vais je vais être un peu clair quand
vous attrapez une personne et qu'elle
vous dit elle vous ment trois fois
quatre fois cinq fois et que finalement
dans les fichiers on l'a sous 13 noms
différents le pire c'est qu'elle vous
dit qu'en plus elle est mineure et
qu'elle a 16 ans voilà la réalité à
laquelle sont confrontés nos forces de
l'ordre aujourd'hui et ben pour régler
ça pour leur donner plus d'outils plus
de moyens on va permettre que la parole
des policiers permet de dire écoutez ce
jeune homme il a de la barbe il a l'air
quand même bien fini on a du mal à
croire que la saison et sa parole lui
permettra de créer une présomption de
majorité voilà quelque chose de très
concret qui va nous permettre de
finalement les garder en centre de
rétention administrative donc il ne soit
plus dans dans qui reste sous la main
qui ne soit plus en liberté pour qu'on
puisse les raccompagner avec un travail
diplomatique parce que les pays dans
lesquels on doit les renvoyer ils
doivent nous donner l'autorisation de
les renvoyer la situation on la connaît
et on la connaît les outils sont en
train d'évoluer et donc si on continue
comme ça à tenir à tenir la fermeté on
continuera à faire évoluer les textes de
loi nous permettant de nous donner plus
de moyens 280 000 entrées irrégulières
détectés par Frontex en 10 mois sur en
Europe 280
000 c'est une ville c'est une ville en
seulement 10 mois plus 77% par rapport à
2021 sur des chiffres qui inquiète les
Européens j'allais dire les Français
mais au-delà des Français les Européens
on voit les élections en Suède on voit
les élections en Italie est-ce qu'il y a
une urgence pour vous vous savez moi je
pense que il y a aujourd'hui un sujet
effectivement de faire évoluer notre
droit parce que nous avons besoin face à
cette tentative à cette estimigration
irrégulière de faire évoluer nos textes
mais la réponse doit être aussi
européenne et la réalité c'est que une
réunion d'aujourd'hui pose l'urgence
mais que notre pays notre gouvernement
n'a jamais eu les pudeurs de gazelle n'a
jamais été flou sur le sujet on sait
toujours non on s'est toujours donné les
moyens et d'ailleurs en 2018 disait au
sujet de l'Aquarius vous l'avez entendu
comme moi il disait que c'était
insoutenable politiquement d'accueillir
ce bateau et là avec le champ de Viking
quelques années plus tard quatre ans
plus tard mais pas un changement de
doctrine ce n'est pas un changement
doctrine aujourd'hui
encore une fois ce n'est pas un
changement doctrine la ligne qui est la
nôtre ça a toujours été celle de l'état
de 3 ça veut dire quoi on respecte la
loi et la loi maritime aujourd'hui
imposée que l'Italie l'accueille
l'Italie a fait le choix parce que c'est
un gouvernement nouveau de laisser
mourir potentiellement des gens en mer
est-ce que on aurait dû faire pareil et
fermer les yeux la réponse est non et je
crois que ça c'est là
comment dire la fierté d'être français
mais la réponse et c'est là où faut pas
laisser la situation se reproduire doit
être européenne et chacun doit prendre
ses responsabilités face à ça on a une
réponse diplomatique mais la réponse
doit être donc il n'y a pas de
changement doctrine on ne fait ni appel
d'air ni effet de changement de jeu de
jambes fermeté ça veut dire oui il faut
raccompagner ceux qui n'ont rien à faire
chez nous encore plus les délinquants
parce qu'ils mettent en danger notre
ordre public et parfois provoque des
drames mais à côté de ça accueillir avec
dignité ceux qui ont le droit d'être
chez nous ou encore qui relève du droit
d'asile parce qu'il fuit la guerre et
parfois malheureusement puisque la
France accueille dignement accueille
nombre d'étrangers on peut largement
réduire les délais parce que aujourd'hui
accueillir dignement c'est réduire aussi
les délais des traitements du droit
d'asile la députée France insoumise
Rachel kéké Franco ivoirienne est allé
soutenir un délinquant radicalisé en
l'occurrence
ivoirien que la France a eu toutes les
peines du monde à expulser un homme de
38 ans
multi condamné multiris délinquant la
France voulait l'expulser est-ce qu'il
est dans son rôle en allant le soutenir
et moi je suis parlementaire
j'ai été élu j'ai eu même la chance que
chez moi à Nantes en Loire-Atlantique on
m'a refait confiance on m'a réélu le
comportement de la députée est plus que
condamnable je ne comprends pas ce
comportement là allez voir une personne
qui est radicalisée une personne en plus
que la France expulse et a décidé
d'expulser très sincèrement c'est
exactement l'illustration du
comportement d'extrême gauche de la
France insoumise allez soutenir une
personne qui est à l'opposé de notre
modèle de société qui en plus a commis
des des crimes et des délits dans notre
sur notre territoire n'a pour moi aucune
compréhension je pense qu'elle aura
vocation à s'expliquer sur ce
comportement d'autant plus que j'ai vu
des images où elle bouscule elle
bouscule elle utilise un peu le un peu
la pression c'est indigne de la fonction
de parlementaire et il y a un soupçon je
dis bien un soupçon de communautarisme
puisqu'elle est ivoirienne française et
ivoirienne et l'homme est ivoirien
est-ce qu'il faut comme le demande
certains élus notamment à droite
supprimer la double nationalité pour les
députés vous savez moi je suis j'ai une
double nationalité
j'ai fait allégeance à la France je suis
né à Romorantin mes parents étaient
marocains ils sont nés au Maroc ils sont
venus dans notre pays et j'ai adopté ces
valeurs son histoire son son héritage
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui je me sens
française oui pleinement parce que je le
suis l'esprit français le génie français
le permet est-ce que cette dame a fait
un acte de communautarisme peut-être à
elle de s'en expliquer mais jeter le
propre sur l'ensemble des parlementaires
des élus et finalement des Français qui
ont fait le choix d'aimer notre drapeau
plus que personne et parfois on versait
le sang de leur de leur famille la sueur
de leur front pour bâtir notre pays je
crois et pour le coup plutôt indigne
soirée chaotique à l'Assemblée nationale
jusque tard hier soir un député de
Guadeloupe s'en est pris un député
Renaissance en lui hurle en hurlant
dessus tu vas la fermer vous avez
certainement vu cette heureusement cette
ce moment c'est invective voilà il était
question de la réintégration des
soignants non vaccinés on va regarder on
est ensemble à nouveau pour ceux qui
n'ont pas encore vu
vous êtes contents d'avoir pu trouver
une petite messe quierie obstrive pour
ne pas laisser une niche aller jusqu'au
bout
tu vas la fermer
non c'est pas possible
qu'est-ce que ça dit
ça dit que malheureusement aujourd'hui
en cette fin de journée qui a été qui a
très bien commencé par le vote de la loi
qui permet à l'IVG de rentrer dans notre
Constitution et donc un signal au monde
absolument essentiel voter de manière
transpartisane qui permet à toutes ces
petites filles de notre pays de
considérer que jamais chez nous on
viendra à remettre en question cette ce
droit ce droit à disposer de leur propre
corps finir la journée comme ça et bien
c'est triste c'est dommage c'est
[Musique]
les comptes de campagne d'Emmanuel
Macron vont être passer au crible c'est
une enquête sensible s'il en est
un commentaire vous savez moi je ne
commande jamais des des procédures de
justice qui sont en cours les lycées je
crois s'exprimer il y a eu un comité de
presse également
donc il n'y a aucun commentaire à
apporter moi j'ai confiance en la
justice de mon pays je crois à l'état à
l'état de droit c'est à dire que la loi
s'applique pour tout le monde de la même
manière donc on verra la suite de ces de
ces investigations le service national
universel c'est votre partie vous êtes
secrétaire d'État à la Jeunesse et au
s&u au service national universel pour
l'instant il est pas obligatoire déjà
combien de jeunes en ont déjà profité
écoutez plus de 40 000 jeunes mais
qu'est-ce que c'est le service
d'anniversaire le service à son
universel c'est d'abord une rencontre
entre des jeunes qui ne se
rencontreraient jamais porte l'uniforme
ce qui leur permet de vivre ce sentiment
d'appartenance à la France il lève le
drapeau il chante notre marseillaise se
rendre compte que s'ils viennent de
Trappes d'Aurillac de Nantes de chez moi
de grands champs des fontaines ou de
Guéret ils ont ensemble un commun et moi
je les ai vu ces jeunes je les ai vu se
transformer ça va faire trois ans que je
le mets en oeuvre 5 ans qu'on le porte
qu'on le qu'on organise et bien moi j'ai
vu des jeunes grandir des jeunes faire
leur livre faire du sport ensemble avoir
finalement la le goût de du commun pour
certains il l'avait jamais pris le train
j'ai jamais quitté leur département
voilà ce que c'est le service universel
c'est d'abord une rencontre une
rencontre des jeunesses de France et ce
qu'il doit devenir obligatoire on dit
que le Président de la République va
faire une annonce bientôt vous savez le
président de la République l'a dit dans
son discours à l'Hôtel de Brienne le 13
juillet dernier
il m'a demandé de préparer de continuer
son plein déploiement sa généralisation
moi ce que je vois c'est à quel point il
est vertueux ce service à son
anniversaire il permet de la mixité
m'exciter territoriale il permet à nos à
nos jeunes de vivre ce patriotisme qui
nous manque tant ce que je sais
qu'il est bon pour eux il est bon entre
eux et il est bon pour notre pays j'ai
faim j'ai formulé ma question
différemment est-ce que vous vous
souhaitez qu'il devienne obligatoire moi
je réponds à la demande du Président de
la République qui est de préparer
évidemment plus de jeunes à y venir ça
généralisation je crois à la force de
l'engagement je crois au goût de
l'effort je crois finalement à ces
rencontres qui permettent d'aller
chercher le meilleur dans chacun de soi
mais surtout je crois à la force morale
de notre pays et la force morale c'est
la capacité de répondre au défi
aujourd'hui qui fracture notre société
de répondre à ce qui se passe par
exemple en Ukraine avec cette création
d'esprit d'un peuple de France le
réveiller le renforcer je crois aussi à
l'égalité des chances celle qui va
permettre à chaque jeune d'avoir accès à
un médecin les bilans illettrisme de
découvrir notre patrimoine mais pour
répondre à votre question le président
de la République aura l'occasion de
s'exprimer quand bientôt il l'a rappelé
encore à Toulon quand il a présenté la
revue stratégique
et il donnera sa vision du déploiement
du service national universel à l'avenir
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans ce qu'on
dit d'un momentum c'est-à-dire que on a
expérimenté on a essayé moi j'ai vu à
quel point ça transformait notre jeune
nos jeunes je suis convaincu du fait que
c'est utile pour la France c'est utile
pour eux et c'est utile pour notre
société un mot s'il vous plaît sur la
d'ailleurs juste pour être j'invite du
coup tous ceux qui le souhaitent aller
regarder exactement et c'est nul.gouv.fr
ou d'aller s'inscrire pour le faire les
inscriptions sont ouvertes c'est sur la
base du volontariat mais quelle fierté
de pouvoir porter les couleurs de notre
drapeau et en même temps d'aller
rencontrer des jeunes qui viennent
d'ailleurs en ayant finalement cette
rencontre avec la France qui est
possible aujourd'hui la journée de lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
comment est-ce que vous jugez la faire
Adrien catenin
aux femmes c'est un drame à chaque fois
qu'il y en a une qui prendra un coup de
poing de la violence physique ou
psychologique ou mentale je ne tire
jamais sur une ambulance aujourd'hui
l'affaire Adrien c'est entre les mains
de la justice ce qui est certain c'est
que je ne laisserai jamais dire qu'une
gifle ce n'est rien ce n'est pas grave
maintenant chacun est facile
mais bien sûr alors le deux poids de
mesure c'est quand même la spécialité de
la France insoumise la spécialité c'est
leur signature moi ce que je vois c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des drames ça mène
à des drames il y a des femmes qui
perdent la vie et des enfants qui voient
leur maman souvent se faire taper se
faire violer se faire insulter dans
notre pays ça n'a pas sa place alors oui
c'est la priorité de notre quinquennat
c'est la grande cause de notre
quinquennat et tant qu'il y a une femme
qui continue à se faire insulter
violenter dans son foyer il y aura à
côté d'elle des policiers des gendarmes
c'est en renforçant leurs moyens qu'on
donne qu'on protège ces femmes il n'a
pas été condamné est-ce qu'il peut
siéger encore à l'Assemblée nationale et
les députés vous savez c'est quasiment
en fonction du peuple qui lui a donné le
droit d'aller sur et l'honneur d'aller
sur les bancs de l'Assemblée nationale
mais c'est aussi un responsable
politique c'est à lui de décider ce qui
est certain c'est que j'ai vu que son
groupe parlementaire la France insoumise
changer quasiment de position et de
décision tous les 72 heures ce qui est
certain c'est que il a reconnu les faits
ça veut dire quelque chose et il a levé
la main sur sa femme merci Sarah et
Larry le 39 19 c'est important si vous
êtes témoin si vous êtes vous-même
victime de violence vous appelez le 39
19 que vous soyez une femme victime de
violence ou un homme victime de violence
car ça existe également dans les dans
les couples merci beaucoup madame la
secrétaire d'État à la Jeunesse et au
service national universel